welcome to clog minute today I'm going
to show you how to enable and disable
api's in the Google cloud platform I'm
working on a new project and when I run
g-cloud compute instances list I get an
error saying that access is not
configured if you run into this it just
means you haven't enabled that API for
your project Google cloud platform
requires you to enable API so that you
are only using the products you want to
use from the developers console click
api's and off and then click API s now
you need to select the API you want to
enable if it isn't listed on this first
page you can search for it using the
search box once you find the API you
want click on the name and then click
enable API
once it finishes enabling I can use the
G cloud compute functions from the
command line if you want to see what
api's are enabled for your project click
AP is enabled ap is and that will show
you a list of the AP is currently
enabled for your project if you want to
disable an API you can do so from here
or you can do so from the api's page
where you enabled it I hope you found
this helpful